Corey Mandell: if you go back 10 or 15 years and you
ask yourself of all the
let's put them in a three different
categories we have paradigm driven
scripts we could also call these formula
driven rules driven so these are scripts
where like if you watch a bunch of three
camera comedies it's the same story
structure just different jokes or you
watch a bunch of superhero movies over
the summer it's kind of the same story
beats are happy at the same time so
these are formula or paradigm driven
scripts so that's one category of
scripts that people can write and try to
sell then there's imitative scripts so
when Breaking Bad Rose the phenomenal
hit everyone was writing their version
of Breaking Bad or people would write
their version of Arrested Development so
you'd read someone's script and you'd be
like oh this is like Mad Men but kind of
different and then the third kind of
script is pitch perfect authentic and so
that would be a script that like when
you read the pilot script for orange as
a new black it's not like anything
you've ever seen it's like orange is the
new black love it
like it hate it it's completely original
we've never seen these characters we've
never seen this world and the story is
not formulaic it doesn't hit these
preordained plot points its unfolds in a
way that's most compelling for what
Jenji Kohan the writer is trying to
communicate Mad Ben's another example
community Sopranos we could just go on
and on moonlight so these are scripts
that don't follow a paradigm they don't
imitate what somebody else did they're a
wholly original piece of work original
characters story and Way of telling that
story so if we go back 12 or 15 years on
the TV market who's buying pitch-perfect
authentic scripts HBO Showtime that's it
everyone else is basically buying
paradigm driven shows genre driven shows
or a show that imitates a successful
show so if you wanted to break into the
business ten years ago even seven years
ago you might follow a formula you might
follow a paradigm also you're looking to
get staffed on a TV show so TV shows
hire lots of writers so if you want to
be a comedy writer you might write an
episode of jane the virgin or episode of
silicon valley
you're a drama writer you'd write a
version of a drama
to prove that you could imitate a show
everything is completely different now
so now when you ask yourself who's
buying pitch-perfect authentic scripts
HBO Showtime Netflix Amazon AMC FX and
the network's basically everybody and
the reason is they're all chasing the
key demographic which is 18 to 49 and
our generation we've grown up on
on-demand video demand platforms so
we've seen so many movies we've seen so
many TV shows we know what's original
and we know what is imitative and by and
large our generation doesn't watch
formula and so basically the the key
demographic wants something that's
original want something that's new and
different and there's so much you can
watch on TV it really needs to be
special to grab your attention and so
you'd be loyal so people are loyal
transparent they're loyal to Game of
Thrones they're loyal to Jane the Virgin
and these are pitch perfect authentic
shows so I've read every script that is
sold in the last three years and the
vast majority are pitch perfect
authentic scripts now there are paradigm
driven scripts that sell their our
imitative scripts that sell but the
people who sell those are people who
have a real serious track record in that
genre and what agents will always tell
my classes is if you have a standard
follow the dots comedy or drama or
procedural unless you've been an
executive producer or above on a hit
show in that space in the last three
years your scripts dead on arrival no
one will even read the script further
showrunners now when they staff shows
they won't look at imitation scripts
they don't want to look at your version
of a show they want to read a
pitch-perfect original script and what
they always tell my classes is if you
can write to a show if you can imitate
my voice if you can follow a paradigm or
a formula that doesn't mean you're a
great writer if you're an amazingly
great writer you can eat my voice you
can follow how I tell my stories so it's
really heartbreaking because there's so
many books and
classes and seminars that probably made
a lot of sense five years ago that are
teaching people these paradigms or
teaching people how to imitate and a set
of rules that no longer applies so it's
like writers are being trained for a war
that doesn't exist anymore and just real
quick in features if you're going to
work for the studios you are going to be
doing a Pixar film a Star Wars film or a
Marvel action film that's basically your
three choices and they Pixar has a way
they tell their stories Marvel has the
way they tell their story Star Wars has
a way they tell their stories but I have
students I just have a student who's got
her first writing job at Pixar but the
script that she wrote was a
pitch-perfect authentic script so even
though when they hire her they're gonna
expect her to write a Pixar script you
don't break in with a Pixar script you
don't break in imitating or following a
formula you break in with a script that
when everyone reads it they go holy moly
who wrote this this is amazing this
writer I have to meet this writer I have
to be in business with those writers so
when you look at the writers who are
writing all the features for the
studio's they either have amazing track
record of credits like Lawrence Kasdan
or they wrote an amazing pitch perfect
authentic script that no one had seen
before blew people away and then
Marvel's like hey would you be
interested in doing our you know
whatever movie we're making and yes at
that point when you got hired you're
certainly gonna write it the way Marvel
wants you to write it but the mistake I
see as so many writers write their
superhero scripts or their paint by the
number of scripts and they can't figure
out why they can't get a career they're
just simply writing the wrong kinds of
scrubs
when I work with writers I separate
story design from story execution so
story design is this so if you were
going on a vacation and you wanted to
have a romantic relaxing vacation and
you ended up in a war zone where people
are literally getting killed
there's no room service because
everyone's dead dead bodies in the pool
can you have a relaxing romantic
vacation and the answer is you could but
it's very unlikely if you go to a very
relaxing romantic resort and
everything's perfect that doesn't
guarantee that you'll have a relaxing
romantic vacation because you still have
to have the vacation and you might be
stressed you might be thinking about
work you might be having a fight with
your partner but if you go to a very
relaxing romantic spot you you get there
in a you know you fly first-class or you
take a night train through Europe and
every the design of your vacation is
just perfect it makes it so much easier
to have a relaxing romantic vacation the
mistake that so many writers make is
they have a problem with their story
design but they try to fix it through
execution so that's like you're in a war
zone let's turn the volume up so we
don't hear the dead people as much let's
take the dead people out of the pool yes
that does make it better but just leave
and go to Hawaii and you'll be in much
better shape so I always start with
story design and make sure people I'm
sorry if I could back up so the key is
when someone's having a problem with
their script is it a problem with design
or is it a problem with execution
because other writers will have a great
design but they'll mess it up in
execution get feedback that it's not
working and throw their design out so if
there's a problem with design and you
keep trying to fix it in execution
that's like rearranging the deck chairs
on the Titanic but at the same time you
might have a great story design that you
just aren't able to find the right
execution so people will often do a
consult with someone and the scripts
pretty good but the ending is terrible
and when I talk to them it always comes
up we're like well that's not my
original ending and I go what is your
original ending and when they tell me
I'm like that's a great ending like I
know but everyone said that I didn't
believe it it was try everyone had
criticisms they were criticizing the
execution
not the design so the sorry about taking
the long way around to the question but
so when I'm working with story design
it's when someone is working from a
formula or a paradigm or a set of rules
first of all you're just not interested
when you hear it it's incredibly
predictable and it just feels generic it
feels like an Ikea piece of furniture
it's like I've seen this story a million
times and the other key thing is at some
point I'll just stop them and I'll say
why does this happen like why did the
character do this and the real answer is
because the writer wanted were needed or
felt like they needed the character to
do this so it's not authentic it's not
organic and it's not the best way of
telling the story it's it's literally
following a recipe
so execution is actually when you're
writing so it's the dialogue it's the
characters it's the comedy it's the
actual writing of it the design is
having the entire story worked out
before you've written a word okay and
you need to be able to create pitch
perfect design and then execute it
authentically where these are real
characters that were compelled with and
everything that's happening feels this
is really what the character would do
but it also is what's really interesting
to the story because the problem that a
lot of writers get into is if they
slowed things down they'd realize that
there's key points in their scripts
where they ask themselves if this was a
real person this character what would
they really do and let's say it's this
they would do this then they ask
themselves from a story point of view
what makes for the most interesting
story and it's that and so some writers
will just do what the character would
actually do and their scripts feel very
organic but they're not strong stories
other writers will follow oh this is
what makes for the best story but so
they have good strong structure but
doesn't feel organic or believable
when I work with writers this is the the
first thing that I teach them and I
think that this is the foundational
skill set and I call it creative
integration and so the way it works is
writers tend to work from one of two
places inside themselves and it has to
do with the brain and there are a
conceptual part of the brain and an
intuitive part of the brain and most
writers tend to be more conceptual or
more intuitive so conceptual writers
tend to work outside in they tend to be
very concerned about the story that the
story is logical that the story makes
sense that the story is interesting to
other people conceptual writers are very
concerned about what other people are
going to think about this writing and
will they think this is good I think I'm
a good writer so they want really
interesting things happening and they
want a lot of interesting things
happening and they want it to make sense
and they wanted to have causality and
that's really really important to them
intuitive writers are completely
different the intuitive part of the
brain doesn't care what other people
think it just cares about what is
authentically true to you so intuitive
writers are navigating towards what they
would do in that situation or just
what's interesting and compelling to
them or what the character would really
do and it's a very different way of
writing one the conceptual is outside in
and the intuitive is inside out so a
conceptual writer would say I have this
great idea and I've got to figure it out
I got to break the story before I could
write it if you don't know where you're
going how you're gonna get there it's a
very systematic logical approach to
writing the intuitive writer is going to
be someone who says I need to write this
out to figure out what the story is they
find it through the journey they find it
through exploring intuitive writers
explore conceptual writers decide and
they each have different inherent
strengths and weaknesses so let's start
with conceptual writers conceptual
writers when you ask them why did you
write this what why is this script
important to you it's almost always a
big idea
a what if something that could be
commercial a new way of doing a comedy I
thought this was a great idea for a
horror film or it's a theme they want to
explore an intellectual theme and so
they're really good at big ideas big
concepts and they're really good at
making sure everything happens for a
reason and there's forward momentum and
there's causality and they have lots of
interesting things happening that we're
just not that interested in and one of
the reasons we're not that interested in
it is their characters are never
compelling enough their characters feel
kind of like they were invented to tell
this story because they work they're
kind of like puppets who are there to
tell the story and we just don't get an
emotional connection to the characters
the other reason that they hit a glass
ceiling they can't get through is
there's all these interesting things
happening in the script but we're not
that interested in them because we don't
feel anything because the writer didn't
feel anything when they wrote it and
it's an energy transference business so
conceptual writers got great ideas lots
of big great things happening but the
characters just aren't where they need
to be and it's just not emotionally
engaging and most of those writers know
that but they don't know what to do
about it and Tudor writers are the
opposite
they bleed on the page and these
characters are like real people to them
they don't invent the characters they
don't designing the characters they
discover them and that's why a lot of
intuitive writers don't often get lonely
when they write because they're spending
time with their friends they're spending
time with people that they care about
and so if I'm working with a conceptual
writer and the characters not engaging
enough they'll say well what can we do
to change it should we make her older
younger let's make her bisexual let's
change or ethnicities let's take her arm
off let's make her a quadriplegic what
can we do to make her if I'm working
with a deep intuitive writer and their
characters aren't interesting enough
that would be like talking to a mom and
saying your daughter's not that popular
at school let's take her arms off let's
make her a quadriplegic let's make her
older if you like that's crazy this is a
real person you can't change who they
are intuitive writers like they're very
connected
to their characters and as a result they
tend to create really compelling
characters really compelling emotion and
these really compelling characters are
forever searching for a compelling story
they can't find because the intuitive
writer is so inside out and so connected
to emotion and character that part of
them cannot create strong story it's the
the conceptual brain has a perpendicular
processor and it has a certain way of
thinking and strength so weaknesses in
to to brain as a parallel processor and
anyone if they're interested you can
email my my assistant which is Lisa at
Quarry Mandel net and we can get you a
bunch of information on this if we're
interested
to take this further what happens is
most writers if not all writers when
they're writing they're trying to write
the best script they can write and if
you're smart and writers are very smart
you play to your strengths and you hide
your weaknesses so if I was a playing
tennis against you for the championship
and I'm really good at my forehand but
I'm weak at my backhand I would try to
play everything to my forehand and hide
my and you of course would try to make
me plate my back here so writers are
always writing to their strengths and
trying to hide their weaknesses and
maybe they know they're doing it maybe
they don't but they're doing it I see
this all the time and so what happens is
over time as their strengths get
stronger and their weaknesses get weaker
and that is why there's so many writers
who poor heart and soul and all this
time and energy to have a career and
they can't get there because your
scripts aren't quite good enough when I
work with the writer I will train them
through creative integration so what we
will do is we will make them write to
their weakness and hide their strengths
so if I'm right hand then do everything
is my right hand and my left hand is
really uncoordinated
I literally tighten my right hand behind
my black my back for a month and I do
every with my left hand it's gonna get
stronger and more coordinated now during
that month I might spill a lot of things
and be very inefficient but over time
I'll develop my left arm and eye
coordination in the strength then I'll
learn how to integrate the two so for a
conceptual writer they will work
exclusively from the intuitive part they
will learn how to turn off the
conceptual part the conceptual part is
the part that has all these big ideas
and worries about story a lot is all
this anxiety and judgement and turn that
off and teach them how to create from a
pure authentic emotional space now their
writing may not be well structured it
may not be something they're going to
show an agent but they will through that
process their characters will come alive
their dialogue will come alive and
you'll one of the key things when I do
intuitive training is to get you to
think about something in your life where
you feel something very strong and then
your writing when other people read it
they're going to feel what you feel so
you can get people to have the emotional
experience you had when you wrote
then when I help you learn how to
discover actual characters there was a
whole bunch of training to get to the
point where that's a real person for you
then you can write that person from what
they're feeling and people will feel
that then you can start putting
characters into conflict and it'll all
be authentic characters and so that's
the intuitive training and when they get
to the point where their characters and
their dialogue and everything is organic
and authentic as best as the best
writers out there then I'll teach them
how to integrate that back to the
conceptual side so that they all have
the best possible stories and the best
possible characters and then obviously
for and into two writers the opposite
they will turn that part of the brain
off they'll work purely from conceptual
until they're a rockstar and then we'll
integrate and that process it's just so
rewarding to work with writers because
it they come out the other end literally
their agent their manager or their
spouse will say they'll read a script
and say I love you but you didn't write
this I hear this all the time I don't
believe you wrote this because your
stories aren't this crisp and compelling
I mean this has all your great character
work but you can't like who helps you
with the stories or someone will say you
don't write characters this great I love
you I love your writing but this is like
you know orange is the new black or
Maddy I mean this is just that high
level of characters and it's like it
literally is transformative
most writers occasionally they have
these flow days where everything is just
pouring out of them and it's so great
you're doing your best material and you
love those days and you wish you could
live in those days and then writers have
those days which is the exact opposite
where you were pounding your head
against the wall just trying to get
something on the page and I think for
most writers that I work with they're
often somewhere in between the really
great thing about creative integration
is almost all your days will be flow
days because this is what cause float
this is what happens when a writer is
writing there's what would be best for
the story what is the best thing to make
the story move forward in the most
interesting way and a lot of writers
especially intuitive writers they don't
know the answer and that's really
confusing and frustrating excuse me now
even if you do know the answer and let's
say it's that then of course what would
my character really do and if it's the
same thing and then you ask yourself
what do I most want to write today what
gets me most exciting about writing day
it's the same thing all three
navigational systems lying up that's a
float that's when it's all coming out of
you it's your best writing you want to
live in those days when you don't know
what the character would do or you don't
know what's best for the story or you
know but this is what's best for the
story this is what the characters do
this is what you most want to write it's
all those are the worst days so but
creative integration does is it allows
people to train and know with a set of
suite of tools what would be best for my
story they'll be able to go to another
part and you know what my character
really do those another part and know
what they're most interested in writing
and then they'll have tools to integrate
which is to bring those three things
into alignment and so I can't say that
every writing day will be a flow day but
most of writers I've trained they'll say
used to be 10 to 20 percent or flow days
now it's like 80% and so they not only
does the quality of the writing greatly
improve but so does the quantity
generally speaking what I would probably
do if I was working with you is the
first thing I would say is we're going
to turn off your intuitive side and
develop your conceptual sight so that
you're going to be able to naturally and
easily build to connect the dots but not
only connect the dots but do it with
real strong stakes and clarity and
strong escalations and you're gonna be
able to create as strong of a story as
anyone in the industry and that story in
a sense is is a glass and then we're
going to teach you how to pour your
characters and your dialogue and your
emotion and all that intuitive stuff
into that structure so that now your
characters and your dialogue will be in
service of a super strong story so and
then usually the writers like oh that's
exciting I want to do that how do I do
that then I say okay well here's step
one I need to imagine that we're gonna
go behind the barn and take everything
that you love about writing and we're
just gonna shoot it in the head and
that's the writers like I don't want to
do that but that's what it feels like
because what we need to do is turn off
that part of you that is that dreamy
intuitive emotional connective and
instinctive part of you now we're not
going to kill that forever that is such
a valuable part of you but we are
literally going to turn it off because
here's the thing if it's on your
conceptual brain can't be on they both
can't be on the same time they're
connected by a corpus callosum and just
physiologically speaking they can't be
on the same time it would it was short
circuit to fight-or-flight mechanism so
we're gonna turn this off and so the
training in the beginning is we're going
to be creating simple stories and then
more complex stories and eventually
scripts but there'll be no characters
and there'll be no dialogue and we are
literally like going to be playing with
just puppets and we are going to be
doing we're gonna I'm gonna drill you
day in and day out week in and week out
on exercises for story logic and for
story company but so if I may back up
the there's a really cool class up there
called drawing from the right side of
the brain I'm sorry yeah drawing fire I
saw their brain and they have their
before and after pictures they have
these people who are terrible
illustrators they do self-portraits and
you look
get it and you're like these I wouldn't
even call these stick figures because
I'd be an insult to stick figures these
are durable drawings and then they have
three days later the same person does
their same self-portrait and it's like
this is amazing like how could someone
in three days go from being such a
terrible drawer to such an amazing bar
and so the key is she has broken down
the drawing into five specific skill
sets and one of them is contrast one of
them is shapes and this is the key she
teaches you contrast or she teaches you
shapes completely separate from all the
others so you can't learn shaping if
you're worried about what the picture
looks like if you're worried about it
being a good picture you just learn
shaping you just learn contrast you just
learn color I actually don't know what
the five things are by heart but you
learn all five things in isolation and
then at the end should usually how to
integrate it so that's what we would do
so we would be drilling you on story
logic and you'd have a whole week of
those exercises but they're not real
characters it's not a script you're
working on these are just training
exercises then we're gonna drill you on
five weeks of story causality then we're
gonna work on logic and clarity and
perspective and then we're gonna be
working on escalation then we're gonna
be creating conceptually strong
characters and moving them and you're
gonna ultimately create a story where we
don't know anything about the characters
we have no emotional connection but when
you look down at that story you're gonna
say that is a clear beginning middle end
it has forward momentum and escalations
if that story was populated with super
compelling characters and dialogue it
could be amazing and you're just gonna
be able to do that over and over again
you probably won't enjoy this training
it probably won't be fun in fact writers
usually complain because they're like
this feels like math and this is I want
to be a writer because I hate math right
when can we do the fun stuff and it's
like you cannot do the fun stuff until
you are an expert at this
I'll give you a true story I am a mentor
for film independent and they have a lab
and they bring in these writers and then
you are mentored by writers and
directors of some of the best
independent films and I came in at the
end sort of clean up where the writer
had all these notes and before they went
to do the rewrite I would work with them
sort of make sure their plan was in good
shape so I kind of came at the end of
the process and I worked with this
writer it's wonderful woman and she had
gone to one the major film schools and
have an MFA and she ever since she was a
little girl all she wanted to do is be a
writer and she she was so excited to get
in this program and she had written the
script and some of the writers and
directors of her favorite movies read
your script and gave her feedback and so
my job is to see what her rewrite plan
is and see if I can bring any value to
it so I go hey how's it going shows it's
going good but she said it and I really
like things are not going good way and I
go so what's going on she goes I quit
and I'm like you're not gonna write this
shows no I quit and I'm like what do you
mean shows I'm not gonna write anymore
I'm done and I couldn't be happier this
is a load off my shoulder and like she
starts crying and it's so sad and this
is a very representative story I see
this all the time so I get in touch why
are you quitting what happened so what
happened is she's this really intuitive
writer and so she's in this program and
she had a character she loved more than
anything and she loved the story more
than anything and she wrote this script
and she said everyone was giving me
feedback they it was like the feedback
was contradictory like they all read a
different script that's what happens
with intuitive writers because they have
no they have no story structure and they
have no clarity and literally everybody
does read a different story so all these
really great writers and directors were
giving her feedback on the stories that
played in their head when they read the
script none of them were the story that
played in the writers head but the real
coup de Gras was she knew she wasn't
good at story structure but she thought
she was great at characters and they all
told her your character is not that
strong you you need a write stronger
character so she said I can't do story
structure and my character is not that
good and these are the best people in
industry telling me that I got nothing
so I have to quit I got nothing to hang
my hat on
so I said well do me a favor before you
quit we just answer some questions and
so she said okay so I asked her all
these questions about her character and
why did you love your character and what
does your character do and tell me about
the story and what happens here and why
does it happen and and we after about an
hour of questions I could really
experience and see what she was seen in
experiencing and it was one of the most
hauntingly beautiful characters and it
was such a great story but I told her I
got almost none of that when I read your
script and the movie that plays in my
head when I read your script it was
really boring and I didn't understand or
care about your character but the
character that you experienced a
character that's inside of you that is a
really powerful character you need to
learn how to develop these conceptual
tools so that you can take this amazing
character this amazing wine and get it
into the right vessel the right
structure not a formulaic structure but
a custom design structure that will
showcase your character in the story you
want to tell and she's like oh I could
never do that I could never in any way
she did end up taking classes from me
and it took her longer than most people
it took her probably a year to get
really strong at the conceptual site and
probably another year to really learn
how to integrate that that she then
wrote that script everybody loved it she
didn't sell it but she got an agent off
of that and now she's a very successful
TV writer and the funny thing actually
is the person who hired her at one point
said you're you're really great with
characters but I did hired you because
you were I just needed someone who's so
good with story and she cuz he had to
call me because he's like I got hired
because they think I'm really good at
story the thing is she's really good at
story it's almost like someone who's
been heavy their whole life and now
they're thin they still think they're
heavy like she still it took a while for
her confidence to catch up to her
abilities so what breaks my heart is
that there's all these intuitive writers
out there and people are reading their
scripts and they're just not that
interesting they're not that good but if
you could know what was playing inside
their heads and their hearts you'd be
like now that's powerful but they don't
know that and they don't train
so it's like how many you know how many
trans parents have the world not had or
how many Sopranos or moon lights how
many of these projects never came to
fruition because there's a writer out
there who has something like that inside
them but they can't get it on the page
where we can experience it
the playwright he has a book called
rewrites which is his autobiography he
talks about like year after year when he
was a younger man he'd write these plays
and he loved the characters and in
everyone thought they were sterically
funny but there was just something
missing it just didn't hold together it
just wasn't interesting enough and over
time he's like I know something's
missing but I don't know what it is and
I know a lot of writers who feel that
way and it's a really terrible feeling
he eventually did the one thing he never
wanted to do is he went to his older
brother who was a really successful
writer and his older brother read his
stuff and said you're not writing a
compelling conflict and Neil Simon's
like what are you talking about what is
this and he said my older brother taught
me what it was and then the light bulb
went off and so then he said I would
just structure my compelling conflicts
and then pour in all the character and
comedy and that's how he did his career
David Mamet and this is on my website or
you can look online he did a memo about
a decade ago or so to the writers of the
unit his TV show and he basically said
you will learn how to write in
compelling conflict or you'll be in the
blanking unemployment line or the bread
line and a lot of f-bombs in this memo
but he's basically saying this is not a
natural skill set for most people you
will learn to do this or you will not
survive
and one of the books that changed my
life as a teacher is mindset by Carol
Dweck I make all my students read it's
the only thing I make them read she
talks about the fix mindset and the
growth mindset and the growth mindset is
okay these two people who their stuffs
popping off the page why what skills
what talent do they have that other
people don't have when the growth
mindset says talent is repeatable
skillsets and maybe you're born with
them
maybe you develop them through nurture
and childhood or maybe you learn them as
an adult it doesn't matter how you
acquire them it's just a skill set
that's repeatable as opposed to luck so
a repeatable skill set is you know you
learn how to drive a car you can drive
you now you can always drive a car right
a bike and so they have the people that
pop off the page they have certain skill
sets certain tools the other people
don't if you can figure out what those
are compelling conflict and then you can
figure how to teach compelling conflict
then you can teach those skill sets to
other people and they can learn that
talent and with so I I have I had a
writer that kind came to me his name's
Gary and he had a manager and he was
always taking meetings but he could
never sell anything he could never get
hired he felt like he was that close to
a career for five years and then at some
point you're like okay but something's
not here something's not working so he
came to me deeply intuitive writer that
he wrote the most amazing characters and
dialogue I didn't all I taught him on
that front was don't change what you're
doing you know like you're amazing just
keep doing that
don't let anyone interfere with that but
on the conceptual side you've got some
real weaknesses and him specifically was
escalations how to keep making things
get strong like keep making things worse
and worse than an organic way that was
his so he was an easy case in that he
had everything but one skill set he was
really missing one skill set so I gave
him those training exercises and then
unbeknownst to me when I was done with
that class he spent the next three
months
doing those training exercises everyday
for four hours I didn't know that that's
a growth mindset guy that's a guy he was
like I want to become an expert at this
skill set that I naturally am terrible
at and at the end of those three months
he was as good at that as a natural
conceptual writer is good at that he was
just as good at that as anyone he now
has a movie coming that I think it's
released in the fall starring what's her
name anyway not Reese Witherspoon but
someone like anyway he has a movie that
that come out he has kima see agents who
sold to TV pilots and he had everything
but that one skill set now at the same
time I've worked with writers who are
graded escalations and great at big
concepts but their character is in
dialogue it's just like these are
puppets and through the intuitive
training they could come off the other
end where their characters and dialogue
are just as good as these people who are
naturally great so the key is you have
natural talents and then there's talents
that you don't have or you're not that
strong yet if you train the right way
you can if you're willing to put the
time and effort in the right way you can
end up being just as talented as someone
who's naturally that way and that's the
growth mindset
the fixed mindset first of all believes
that if you want to be a rioter you
either have this talent or you don't so
then it's you are constantly have this
voice in your head that says do I have
what it takes do I have the talent am I
wasting my time am I gonna get a career
or is it never gonna happen for me
that constant cheer bait fear-based
chatter is that fixed mindset and
because of that the fixed mindset and
you have such a smart question it
desires an outcome so if I have a script
and I go hey will you guys read my
script and just give me your feedback I
wanna know what you think there's the
fixed mindset in the growth mindset and
they're both there I don't think it's
one or the other I think they both exist
it's just sort of a ratio are you 90
percent growth mindset and 10 percent
fix for the visit when I give you guys a
script to go just tell me what you think
my fixed mindset wants an outcome it
wants you to to say well now I know why
you had a career now I know why you
teach others this is maybe the best
script I've ever read I am I'm literally
in awe to be in the same room with you I
didn't know human being could write this
this well this is this was the most
amazing script ever like that's what my
fixed mindset wants to hear and when it
doesn't hear it it's going to throw a
temper tantrum and at that point it has
two choices and only two choices which
is what's wrong with you guys or what's
wrong with me so you always hear writers
out there say yeah my manager said that
the characters weren't strong enough you
know I got changed managers I mean he
doesn't know what he's talking about or
they'll say yeah the manager said the
characters weren't good enough I don't I
don't know why I need no good at
characters there's something wrong with
you there's something wrong with me
that's the only choices that it has the
growth mindset does not crave or desire
an outcome it desires the truth so the
growth mindset wants to know what did
you honestly think and why did you think
it and let's say that there are parts of
my script that you really loved and
there was a section of the script that
you just didn't care for why
and not in a defensive way and not in an
attacking way but why because it's like
a detective it's like hmm what plays in
my head is amazing it's not amazing for
you I want to know why where is that
disconnect maybe there is a piece of
information or context that I knew that
you didn't I didn't get out well enough
and if I could just rewrite it so that
becomes more viscerally clear to people
maybe you'll then have the experience in
law maybe that section I like it for
very personal reasons but it actually
disconnects from this there's a whole
million reasons but if I and maybe maybe
the reason you didn't love my script the
honest truth is the characters just
weren't compelling enough for you they
felt kind of flat they felt kind of like
they all spoke the same way
that's not now a rewrite which is the
mistake most people make that is okay
I'm not yet strong enough at characters
or the story the character debate but it
kind of wandered around and it just it
just didn't seem like it had that
forward thrust and maybe I'm just not
good at that forward thrust great that
growth the fixed mindset of course is
freaking out but the growth mindset is
celebrating because it's like okay now I
know what I can do moving forward to get
better as a writer now I got to figure
out how do I train myself to get better
at forward thrust or forward better at
characters and so if you follow a growth
mindset when you get feedback if you
love my script top to bottom and I know
the process that I use to create it and
I can replicate that process that is
great news for me if you didn't love my
script top to bottom and I can talk to
you in the right way to figure out why
you didn't wear the disconnects were and
I could realize where I have a weakness
where I need to get better at a skill
set where I need to create a new talent
or get better at a talent and I can
figure out how to do it that's amazing
so the growth mindset is not looking for
an outcome it's looking for the truth so
your question was really profound those
18 people did they want to know that
they are in 18 people if you ask them
they all say yes the reality is if you
were to tell them and I never did I
never I that was for right or wrong
reasons that was a lying I would never
cross I would never tell someone if I
thought they had what it took or didn't
I just didn't want it because I felt
like that's just my opinion
what is my opinion worth at the end of
the day and I don't want to inflict that
on someone positively or negatively so I
don't know I'm not saying this was them
of the right decision but as a teacher
to this day if someone says do you think
I have what it takes right well first of
all I say go read mind set because
that's a fixed mindset question but even
if I actually have an opinion I'll never
tell someone anyway but if I if someone
were to tell those people the they would
say I want to know the truth and that is
true for their growth mindset but their
fixed mindset does not want to know the
truth it wants an answer it wants a
specific answer it won't say yes or the
fixed mindset would be okay with I don't
think you have what it takes but I don't
think it will take that long for you to
get there the fixed mindsets like
alright I'll settle for that but
anything beyond that and then the fix
mindset it's like well what do you know
or yeah I don't you know so and the
reality is what I've learned is that we
are always both six mindset and growth
mindset and if you really do the work
you can feel you know kind of the ratios
and in fact like people often ask me why
I teach and there's a lot of answers but
I'll tell you one of the main reasons
that I do this is as a writer I had a
very unhealthy relationship with my
writing it was really torturous
experience because as a writer I was
about as fixed mindset as you could be
as a teacher I'm about as growth mindset
as you can be so for some reason
teaching is that one space in my life
where it is just so easy to be egoless
and growth mindset and you know for
other people maybe that's religion or
parenting
or whatever for me it's teaching not
sure why but it is and I didn't even
know about mindset at the time that's
something I learned later on a brilliant
student said hey you should read this
book I think and it was like oh my god
where's has been my whole life and but
yeah so for me teaching I'm sorry
writing had all these demons and and
anxiety and fears and it was just this I
was it was a very angry person and it
was either what the f is wrong with my
agent or this executive and this and
just or what is wrong with me and that
was are my only two choices and as a
teacher its allows me to live in a
growth mindset place and to be a much
it's very healing for me and it's just I
get so much out of that and then I
really love working with writers and
really helping them find and stay in
that growth mindset because that is so
important to a writer
I was in a writing group and there were
some professional writers there's
actually Academy award-nominated writer
we met at her house so that was really
exciting and I had written the script
they were giving me feedback and long
story short it got to the point where
they're like this scripts amazing this
script will sell the only question is
how much it will sell for do you want
help getting an agent and of course that
was like magic to my ears and then I
mentioned this to my professor at UCLA
who you know a lot of really big writers
had come through that scrolling through
his class and so he volunteered to read
the script and he goes this is one of
the three best scripts I've ever read in
20 years at UCLA and again I'm thinking
of all these amazing writers that so I'm
like well I guess I'm as good as those
and he goes this will definitely sell
you want help in getting the manager an
agent and I was interning for a manager
at the time just as an intern so as a
favor as a favor to that manager I'm
like do you want to read this cuz I'm
like it's going to sell it see what do
you want your 10% or not buddy
and so he agreed to read it took like
three weeks which drove me crazy and
then we had a meeting I'll never forget
I go in there and he's like this is a
pretty good rough draft don't show it to
one in the industry because when you
show stuff to people industry they get
coverage reports on it and those are
database that's your first impression
but if it's not great coverage you
haven't just blown your chances at that
production company they're gonna share
that coverage with everybody it's a
database so you you've blown your first
impression across the board and he said
this will not serve you well but you
have some real strengths you have some
real weaknesses you have you know some
blind spots I could help you with that
if you're Enys giving me this whole talk
and the whole time I'm like what is
wrong with him
and like did I tell you what they can't
you were nominated persons I sent my
professor who represented Stevens or you
know top Stevens it wasn't anyway you
know and he said look they were all
telling you the truth this is a better
script than most scripts it's an
impressive script but it's not nearly as
good as what you need in the industry
you look your people in the writing
group are working writers your professor
at UCLA all smart people but they're not
in the business of breaking writers into
the business
I know how good something has to be this
isn't close and I'm like didn't want to
believe that my fixed mindsets like he's
an idiot and so what he said and all
this was the best thing anybody could
have said is hire three studio readers
pay them under the table
if this script came through the tracking
system what coverage would you write and
then give me the coverage the honest
coverage and the coverage isn't good
it's not going to hurt you because it's
it's just you only see it nobody else
sees it and I didn't have a lot of money
but I did this I paid him like a hundred
hundred fifty bucks three different
people someone had imagined someone at
Warner Brothers and so when it Scott
Rudin's company and the coverage came
back and it wasn't terrible
and it wasn't bad it was okay which is
terrible it would have hurt me it was
clear that this coverage was like this
is okay not being special nothing great
here and then on the writer it says you
know recommend consider it was low marks
on the writing on two of the three and
that you can't hide from that and then
the manager said I'll work with you if
you're willing to put your ego at the
door and do this training so I did and
it was like 14 months it was grueling he
was he was not a good person but bet his
training was good it was it was marine
it was much rougher than it had to be
but okay and at the end of that time he
said I now think the script is where it
needs to be all pay for coverage reports
and he paid for three coverage reports
with three different people real actual
readers and it was all just exactly what
you want exceptional coverage and
literally three weeks later Ridley Scott
hires me to write Metropolis I flies me
to London I mean like my whole world
changed my whole life changed and it
never would have happened if that
manager hadn't sort of forced me to pay
for coverage and so because at some
point in a fixed mindset can't hide and
that's what I always tell people if
you're thinking like the biggest mistake
you can make is go out to the
marketplace before
and just because your friends think it's
great and just because your teacher
thinks it's great and just because the
script consult and you hire it is great
and I I don't do anymore I used to do
script consulting but I say don't listen
to those people because they often
they're running a business and a
business wants happy repeat customers so
they often tell you what you want to
hear and even if you find the script
consultant who has incredible integrity
which is rare but they exist they're not
in the business of rating writers into
the business and and I wouldn't listen
to their advice per se I know people who
are like I am the script consultant said
this this and this I went out to the
marketplace look at the coverage it
stunk it happens all the time
I say hire actual readers under the
table in TV or feature wherever you are
and get the actual coverage report that
they would get and if all three coverage
reports come back recommend recommend
highest marks then you're ready to go up
then then yeah get on the highest
mountain pound your chest and get
everybody to read your script if that's
not the case
stay off the radar you don't want people
reading your material it's gonna hurt
you and figure out how you can train
yourself to get better so sorry for a
long answer but no I was very fixed
mindset and if that manager hadn't done
that for me I'd be taking classes a day
I wouldn't be teaching them
I love my agent I think he's the best
agent in the world I'm wrapped that
repped at WME there was another agent w
me Amy who I think is the second best
agent they rolled in her name is Audra
NAT al Berg Eddie and she said something
once that I think is so important for
writers to hear she said that some
writers get it and some writers don't
get it and the writers who get it are
all working and the writers who don't
get it most of them aren't working and
so as an agent she just wants to work
with writers who get it and this is what
it is a lot of writers think that you
know to write a script that changes your
life to write a script that gets you
your first job or to get really Scott to
hire you or to get a show whatever it is
you're aspiring to you have a career if
you're trying to take it to the next
level they think it's about writing that
having the right script at the right
time at the right place that's not it
and that's a mistake that surrenders all
control and power to the universe the
reality is your job is to think in six
script cycles and you have to be writing
the right kinds of scripts pitch perfect
authentic we talked about that earlier
and assuming you trained yourself not to
bill to do that you need to write six of
those every two years and the reason is
if you write six of these pitch perfect
authentic scripts one of them is going
to go out to the marketplace and just
fizzle and you'll never know why and
then two or three of them will go out
and they'll start to get some traction
but then something will happen in Doral
it and then there'll be one or two
that's absolutely going to happen you
have the director tats you have the
stars there's a bidding war there's no
way it's not gonna happen and something
at the very last second is gonna derail
it and one of the six will actually go
the distance and sell or it'll be that
script that gets you the next three or
four years of getting staffs on show
there'll be one of those six scripts
that will just catch lightning in a
bottle one of those sex you don't know
which one it'll be so if you're not
working right now
you ought to be writing three or four of
these scripts a year because you're
thinking and six script cycles so any
one script goes out and ultimately
doesn't do what you need to do you don't
feel like a victim that's one of six
this is the key if you are working you
have two jobs now you have your day job
and your weekend night job so if your
day job as a feature assignment for
Ridley Scott or your day job is you just
got staffed on Jane the Virgin one of my
students just if I keep saying Scott
staff she's very excited you have to do
everything you after that you have to
excel at that job but then at night so
we can you got to be writing pitch
perfect authentic scripts and maybe
you're not writing three or four a year
maybe you're writing two a year because
but you don't stop writing these scripts
and creating these scripts because one
of these scripts is going to be the
thing that takes your career to the next
level and so the writers that don't get
it is I'm working I'm making money I've
made it plus I'm busy it's like I have a
family I am writing there's no other
time and I get that but the reality is
the writers that get it even though
they're working they're still always
creating these new material and they
think about it in six script cycles and
so a lot of times
agents dropped the writers who aren't
doing that and you know I get it because
like when I was a working studio writer
I wasn't continuing to write the scripts
I was just doing my studio assignment
work and I was making good money and I
was really I was too busy I didn't want
to do that
my agent kept telling me to do this I
didn't and he said at some point your
writing career is going to end badly and
I worked non-stop for 11 years but I was
a working writer but I never became an
a-list writer and the only way I could
have become an a-list writer is to keep
writing the script so there was another
writer Erik singer who wrote a script
and he started getting all these studio
assignments and he was making a lot of
money but he kept writing on his own
time he's pitch perfect authentic script
year after year after year and
eventually one of them hit and it was
American hustle and so he's now suddenly
a huge writer I know the guys that wrote
the NIC same thing you know they're
their staff writers and they were making
really good money but they were writing
stuff that they really believed in and
the Nick was one of them and that's that
script just took them to a whole other
level Alan Ball if I may
we can go on and on and on so often
agents drop writers who might be really
great writers but they don't get it they
don't keep creating this new absolutely
so it's either they don't keep creating
material or they're not creating the
right kind of metric it's not good
enough I have a lot of friends or agents
and if you keep creating the right kind
of content even when you're working in
the contents amazing and you play well
with others it's very unlikely they're
going to drop you because that's exactly
the kind of person they want to
represent and in that case if they drop
you it it could be a conflict with our
client it could be a lot of things have
nothing to do with you but if you're not
doing all of those things and an agent
drops you then you have to look in the
mirror
I think that TV writing and feature film
writing are different art forms there's
a lot of overlap but they're very
different so I think that someone has to
first of all say do I want to be a
feature film writer or don't want to be
a TV writer now it's possibly possible
they want to do both but generally
writers have a preference to one or the
other now that said there is so much
more opportunity and money in TV than
there is in feature features are getting
better but not as good although I know a
lot of TV writers who are sneaking over
to the future' neighborhood because
there's a lot less competition but that
said I do have clients and students who
want to be feature film writers but want
to become TV writers as their day jobs
while they keep writing their moonlight
or their Manchester by to sea or
whatever they're writing but what I
would say is you know there's this
training of all the creative integration
and skill sets and then when you really
get to that the the last train of really
designing and executing on your stories
and your characters it's there's
different training for TV or feature so
I would say if someone is sort of new
this whole game I pick one of those
forms and really get strong at that
before you try it learn the other I
wouldn't be bouncing back and forth
because then you kind of become kind of
good but not grated either
now if someone's really great at one for
me I focus on the other so it is really
hard to sell a feature film original
script but it's getting a little bit
easier which means it's gone from
impossible to almost impossible full of
it
it I ain't I have in the last two months
I've had four four students sell feature
scripts and so it is certainly possible
but you see more action on the the TV
side but I think the mistake that a lot
of people make is they want to go buy a
TV script because they think that it's
there's more action and it's easier but
their heart's not really into it they
don't really want to be a TV writer or
not really trained to be a TV writer and
they're wasting their time so I maybe
I'm a romantic but I just think that
there's gonna be so much training and so
much dedication and sacrifice
to get into this business and and what
people don't understand is that getting
in the business as hard as that is
there's a lot easier than staying in the
business and if you're gonna go through
all of that then do it for a career that
you want do it for a life that you want
I mean TV writing and future film
writing is very different
I was the future phone writer for 11
years I had total control of my schedule
I would take meetings maybe one or two
maybe one or two days a week but only
when I wanted to most the time I I could
be in Europe writing I could be here
writing I could do what I had so much
control over my schedule I would work
really intently on something for three
or four months and I could take two
months off TV writing is very different
you're gonna be working maybe eight nine
months intensely and then you get time
off you're gonna be working in a room a
lot with other people
some people love that some people hate
that there is a lot more politics that
can go in the TV writing some people can
thrive in that some people hate that now
its feature film writer I would
constantly be writing scripts pouring
heart and soul into something ever got
made my friends a friend who was a
writer on Mad Men and she would write
something and then you know a few months
later we could watch it
and I was so jealous of that she was so
jealous that I did my work literally in
Paris for two months at one time she was
very jealous of that so I would say like
think about your life I think what I
always tell writers is if I couldn't
guarantee you success writing for movies
or TV which would you pick and whichever
one you pick if I could guarantee you
success writing any kind of thing you
know any kind of TV show comedy drama or
a movie what would you pick and then
work backwards from there to see what
kind of spec scripts you should be
writing and so have a vision for what
kind of career you want what kind of
life you want work backwards and write
those kinds of scripts and that's plan a
and hopefully plan a it will work now
over enough period of time a plan a is
not working you can consider Plan B Plan
B is would be the easier script to sell
where where's the market plate how do I
game the marketplace
that doesn't set you up for the life you
want or the career you want that's just
I want an agent I want to sell something
the mistake that I made that I hope
others don't make is Plan B was my plan
a I was in film school and I said eh I
heard the story how Jim Carrey and I'll
know this is true or not I was a
struggling comic and he said someone
told him to do this he wrote a check to
himself for 1 million dollars and he
post-dated it a year later
and he said in one year I'm gonna be
able to cash this cheque and within one
year he got living color and he made
millions of dollars is that a true story
I don't know I hope so I don't know but
I was 23 years old when I heard it so I
thought it was a true story so I didn't
write my I was I started by a check but
it was I just couldn't do that but I did
write in my calendar one year later I
will have an agent and I will have sold
the scribe I wrote that in that account
I told everyone a year from now I'm
gonna do that so my when we were walking
we move in the direction of where we're
looking that's our intent
so that was my intent in one year I'll
have an agent in celle script and it was
actually 13 months later so I didn't
quite make it I had an agent
I actually didn't sell a script but I
sold a pitch to Ridley Scott and he flew
me to London and was on the front page
of variety so I was willing to call that
a success
okay and what I realized as after I
finished metropolis and it was on the
front page of variety Ridley was gonna
make it and he said very positive things
about the script and me I was named on
the front page of riot II made my mom's
day and it's something I was the hot
writer in town and I was getting all
these job offers and I remember thinking
all these offers that I'm getting are
four kinds of things I don't really want
to be writing so I called mage and I'm
like I don't want to be writing those
kind of things I'm so stupid I'm like
I'll be writing these kind of things so
get me those kind of offers and I forget
what she said she said it's such a
polite classy smart woman but she
basically said you idiot if you wanted
to be doing this why did you write this
script in Metropolis everything you
wrote lines you up for this career if
you don't want this career and you want
that career why did you write those
scripts why did you sell metropolis and
the honest answer is because I was just
trying to get an agent and sell
something I haven't
I was 24 years old I didn't I was so
fixed mindset I said if I can't sell a
script in a year I'm going to law school
because if I don't solve script in a
year means I don't have what it takes
which is very fixed mindset and very
stupid and so I tell people don't make
the mistake I made
Plan B is okay I just want to get an
agent I just want to sell something I
just want to validate I can do this the
plan a is what career do I want what
life do I want and reverse engineer but
you should be writing to give yourself
of that
what I'd like to do is give the single
best piece of advice that I ever got
that I ignored and so what happened is
when I was in the front page of variety
and all these offers were coming in
there was an agent at my agency Barbara
Dreyfus who didn't represent me that she
took me out to lunch and she gave me the
following advice she said the next
script you write is the most important
script you'll ever write it will
determine the trajectory of your career
so right now you were an unknown person
now you're on everyone's radar you work
with a high profile director he's
planning on making the movie he said how
great your script was everybody in town
wants to work with you so everyone is
like so hyped up on you now there are
writers who are commodity writers they
they go in and they write these big
summer movies and these big action
movies they make a lot of money but
there's nothing special about them then
there's writers who are als writers
writers who have these amazing careers
the next script you write will put you
on a trajectory so her advice was this
don't take any job that you wouldn't
have done for free which is to say you
love this project and you believe you
could just knock it out of the park you
love this so much
you would do it without getting paid now
we're gonna get you paid but don't take
anything that falls short of that and
you'll have to say no to a lot of stuff
because most of what they're gonna offer
you is crap or just not a good fit for
you and the offers will start to slow
down and you're gonna panic and think
you have to grab the next best one don't
and the offers will keep slowing down
and I'm telling you this that even
you'll think the offers will eventually
go away and they won't but even if they
do literally you've said no to
everything spec your next script and
make it something that you love and
knock it out apart because she said if
the next one's amazing then that puts
you on a trajectory that then people see
you a certain way later on is the time
to do it for the money later on we'll
grab a lot of money but right now this
next script that you're on now everyone
knows who you are
this next script is going to tell them
what kind of writer you are and when she
said that like
I had that chill up my spine that this
is absolutely true I need to hear this
and do this and I said no to something I
said no to something the third time I
said no it was a Disney project and they
doubled my quote and I said no and they
doubled my quote and I said yes and I'm
embarrassed to say that that project of
all the projects was not only a script I
didn't want to write it was a movie I
wouldn't even want to see but it was
sudden I don't come from money I had
student debt and it was more money than
I ever thought you could make in years
and and I was gonna get paid for three
months and so the precedent that I said
I think with myself at that point is I'm
in this for the money and and I and that
really locked me into a career path and
it was I wish I could go back in time I
feel like that was a really big test and
I failed it if I hadn't taken that
project and that project never got me
and you know as a writing sample I think
it was it was good but it wasn't special
if I'd waited and waited and took
something else or even to something
original and if it was great I would
have made so much more money down the
wrong down though I mean so you know my
agent you know represents me but he also
represents Aaron Sorkin I work non-stop
as a studio writer for 11 years I made a
lot more money than ever thought I could
make do you know the difference between
how much money Aaron Sorkin is me I
don't know but I can I'm sure that what
Aaron Sorkin makes is not even in the
same zip code is what I made he also
represents JK Rowling now I'm not saying
that I could have become Aaron Sorkin or
that level or I could have been JK
Rowling I don't know but what I do know
is that the choices I made prevented
that from being a possibility I was a
studio writer I just kept doing a bunch
of action movies and summer action
comedy movies sometimes I thought they
were fun sometimes
but I love the paycheck and I love just
making the money in the deal and I never
stopped and wrote from my heart I never
wrote and I'll tell you one of the main
reasons is I was so fixed mindset I was
so afraid of rejection I was so afraid
that every script I wrote I was afraid
that people would say oh you're not that
good of a writer you were fraud now if I
wrote something from my heart if I wrote
something that was authentic that
exposed me into the material now they
could say you're not a good writer and
you're not even a good person like they
could reject me as if they rejected my
material and it was very personal then I
would feel like they were rejecting me
as a person and that was too painful I
was not gonna allow it happen my agent
was begging me to write something
authentic and from my heart my wife was
begging me my manager was begging me my
golden retriever was begging me and I
just wouldn't and so it's just it's just
a it was short-sighted
first of all money isn't everything but
even if money is everything I
potentially could have made so much more
money but more importantly I could have
written stuff that I was in love with
and I could have look maybe I would have
I could have tried for that career I
could have written authentic stuff I
could have swung for the fences I could
have tried for that a-list career and
maybe come up short and and then backed
in the career I had maybe that I there's
no I don't know but I know that the
choices I made meant I was never gonna
have that career I was never gonna be
creatively fulfilled I was never gonna
be writing the stuff that I really want
to be writing I was never gonna be
writing from love I was always even
writing from fear I regret that and so
part of the reason I teach is I want to
help writers do it the right way and
help empower them with the tool I wish
someone taught me creative integration
up front and some of the stuff but I I
hope that I can be an influence on
writers so that they can have the best
possible career that they're capable of
and maybe even a better one than that
when I teach a class at UCLA or my
private workshops there's all these
people that just want to be professional
writers have no idea what it's like to
be a professional writer and I don't
think you ever know until you do it and
so it's just I want to be a freshman
writer and I had a vision of what that
would be I think most people's vision is
they sit in a room or in a room with
other people but let's say I sit in a
room and I write what I want to write
and I write it in a way that I want to
write it and I write what I love and
everyone else will love it it don't work
that way people have a process to how
they write and that process usually is
what's comfortable because it plays
their strengths and Heights and
weaknesses and it's learning how to
write in a way that other people love it
as much as you love it and it takes a
lot of work and a lot of training and
then there's deadlines and there's
politics it's there's a lot that goes
into having a writing career beyond just
the writing I mean the reality was like
you have two careers you have the
writing you know you have you have to
create the content but then there's the
career management and the meetings and
the marketing and always be looking for
your other job there's a lot that goes
into it but at the same time I mean to
get paid and to be able to make a living
playing with characters and playing with
stories and and doing something that
especially if it's creatively fulfilling
and you get paid for it you know for for
people who do it right and train
themselves the right way they literally
do something that they would do for free
and they get paid and perhaps they get
paid millions of dollars perhaps they
get paid tens of millions dollars
perhaps they get paid hundreds of
thousand dollars drops they get paid
$100,000 to do what you would do for
free dad actually is possible and I have
a growing list of clients and students
who have that lifestyle so I think
anyone who really is drawn to this
should absolutely pursue it you know and
just pursue it in the right ways
so it is really difficult in the
beginning and a lot of writers have this
fantasy or this illusion and I did and I
was wrong is that you know you're you're
working and you're making money and you
know and you're trying to write and
you're so busy and writing so hard and
and it god when you sell something when
you get hired then you don't you can
quit your day job and you can quit this
and you can just write and uh what a
luxury that would be because you're so
time starved but when you first break
like when I first broke in the business
you know I had two months to write the
script for metropolis but almost every
day I had meetings and I had to go in
meetings and I was talking about other
projects and pitching and it I actually
was spending more time on that than I
was on my day job so I actually had less
time to write and you had just pulled in
so many directions and so discipline
really matter so one of the things that
I teach writers from the very beginning
non you know writers who were starting
out and then the what and a lot of them
won't do this but the ones that do not
only do they become better writers this
will save their rear ends when they have
a career is I teach them the idea of a
writer or schedule so what that means is
if you have a job that pays the bills in
Thursday at 3 o'clock you have to do a
marketing proposal to your boss I know
where you're gonna be Thursday at 3
o'clock you're gonna be doing that
proposal if you don't feel like it and
you don't like the Raposa Liz that good
you're still gonna do the best you can
and if you feel like watching TV or
you're napping you're gonna be there or
you're not gonna have a job and you know
from 10 a.m. to 12 p.m. you are supposed
to meet with this client you're going to
do that and you schedule your life
around that so what I tell people is no
one is going to treat you like a
professional until you are a
professional no one's going to invest
money in you until you put the money
where your mouth is so you have a career
perhaps you have a family perhaps you
have all of these poles on your time I
get that every Sunday night you're gonna
create a writer's schedule for the next
week and maybe you could only write 45
minutes a day ideally an hour or two
hours let's say 90 minutes a day you
will block out that writing time
at 7:30 in the morning be at 6 o'clock
whatever it is for everyday for that
week now if you've blocked out Thursday
from 7:30 to 8:30 is your writing time I
know where you're gonna be at 7:30
you're gonna be writing and it's not if
you feel like it because that's like
your marketing meeting with your boss
so you schedule out your writing time
every single week and then you honor
that and if you're not willing to do
that and you're not willing to honor
that why should anyone else invest money
in you and so the writers who will
adhere to that and have that writer
schedule and stick to it before they
have a career then when they have a
career when they have that beginnings of
a career because the games are career
you have so much demands on your time
and all of these meetings and you need
to take these meetings you need to
strike while the iron is hot you it
really saves them because they'll carve
out that time and they'll put everything
around that writing time so I think a
writing schedule is really really
important
what I tell writers and what I see the
successful writers do is they live in
1992 so but they what they'll do is
often now depends let's say this person
is a morning writer so basically let's
say they get up at I don't know they get
up they do their exercise or they have
their breakfast and they have their
three hours of writing and that's going
to end at 12 o'clock from 9:00 to 12:00
so from the moment they wake up until 12
o'clock they have no internet they will
turn their router off and where you can
actually program your router to go off
or you can program it so they don't
check emails they don't check text they
don't check their phone they live in a
pre-internet world until 12 o'clock and
they don't their phone is turned off now
actually no one writer and I thought
this is this was brilliant they were
like just in case my wife needs to get a
hold of me they actually got a pager it
was really hard to find a pager but you
can you can actually go 1992 if you get
a pager he's got a pager and the only
person that has that number is his wife
and his agent but his agent knows you
only page me if it's an emergency
and same thing with his wife and so he
has his pager there but that's all he
has no other electronics that work and
um and then at 12 o'clock he joins 2017
and he takes his meeting and or people
do that at night or the afternoon but I
would say for your writing time it party
like it right right like it's 1992